ich habe heute mitgebracht christian
lindner der hatte mich heute sehr
überrascht aber bei uns zu gast bei bild
live zum exklusiv-interview und er hat
sich für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
ausgesprochen das hat mich doch sehr
überrascht dass der obmann der liberalen
partei sich für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ausspricht natürlich gibt es
viele gute gründe für die allgemeine
impfpflicht ist würde ich auch gar nicht
weg reden ich selber bin geimpft aber es
gibt auch gute gründe
nein zu einer impfpflicht zu sagen im
grunde genommen das recht auf
körperliche unversehrtheit die meiner
meinung nach
entscheidungsfreiheit die wir einfach
den leuten lassen müssen ja wir müssen
leute von mir zu überzeugen aber es
sollte am ende des tages die eigene
freie entscheidung sein was passiert
jetzt die liberale partei ist umgefallen
und dadurch finde ich finde in unserem
parlament sollte sich innerhalb des
demokratischen raums beziehungsweise
außerhalb der extremen sollten sich
mehrere meinungen wiederfinden als nur
ein striktes jahr zur impfpflicht und
was herr lindner damit gemacht hat er
hat einfach diese position dieser meiner
meinung nach nicht komplett um
vernünftige haltung ja zur impfung aber
nein zur impfpflicht und ja zur
entscheidungsfreiheit diese liberale
position aber jetzt rausgeschoben in die
extreme und das finde ich für unsere
gesellschaft aktuell leider gottes sehr
gefährlich
sebastian ich finde der vorwurf er sei
ein umfaller finde ich ungerecht ich
erwarte von politikern dass sie
dazulernen und ich finde wenn sich die
situation ändert hat ein politiker auch
das recht seine meinung zu ändern ich
finde das authentisch und ich finde das
richtig wenn politiker zu lernen in dem
speziellen fall was die sache anbetrifft
wo sich sagen bin ich natürlich
vollkommen deiner meinung ich habe
nochmal bei dem gründervater also großen
vordenker der der des englischen
aufklärung john lobb nachgeschaut dem
der schon lockt ist der gründungsvater
des liberalismus
wenn du so willst und da ich hab's mir
noch mal aufgeschrieben john locke der
mensch ist von natur aus mit elementaren
freiheitsrechten ausgestattet die keine
irdische macht in frage stellen darf der
staat ist nur ein zweckverband schreibt
er zum gegenseitigen schutz von wie er
schreibt life liberty und estate also
leben freiheit eigentum das heißt er ist
ein garant vor staatlicher
freiheitsrechte und jetzt kommt der
entscheidende satz essen nicht dazu da
um das gemeinwohl zu fördern
fast wörtlich ist übrigens dass die
unabhängigkeitserklärung der vereinigten
staaten eingegangen also keine kuriose
seiten meinung sondern schon lockt der
große liberale aufklärer auf dem diese
ganzen liberalismus im grunde fust mit
john stuart mill und ein paar anderen
sagt der staat ist nur dafür da deine
persönlichen freiheitsrechte zu
verteidigen und darf nicht das
gemeinwohl
opfern also darf nicht die persönliche
freiheit opfern für das gemeinwohl da
kann man anderer meinung sein aber ich
finde christian linder verstößt
natürlich damit eigentlich gegen das den
grund ethos die grund maxime des
liberalismus und damit fehlt mir jetzt
auch eine liberale partei im bundestag
nicht nur an die liberale partei sondern
ich finde leider gottes im
demokratischen raum gibt es nur meine
meinung und das finde ich gefährlich
aber die die frage der partei ist doch
ein der stelle gar nicht so entscheidend
weil olaf scholz hatte schon angekündigt
ist diese abstimmung ohne fraktionszwang
stattfinden wird das heißt jeder
abgeordnete kann nach seinem eigenen
gewissen abstimmen ob christian lindner
das so oder so findet spielt doch da
eigentlich gar nicht so eine große rolle
na gut er ist schon die führung der
deutschen über rhein und eine grund
liberale position so minister nicht zu
räumen finde ich auch bedenklich also
ich glaube ich glaube muss etwas mich
ein bisschen gestört hat es war die
begründung warum auf einmal für eine
impfpflicht ist
wie gesagt man kann immer seine meinung
auch ändern man sagt okay bin jetzt in
einen 1 koalition und wir haben auch
einen gewissen koalitionszwang wir haben
im koalitionsvertrag geschlossen wir
wollen einige nach außen erscheinen aber
er hat sie heute begründet mit einer
verhältnismäßigkeit und das ist das ist
eine ganz andere begründung man kann ja
nicht vorher sagen okay ich finde es
vorher nicht verhältnismäßig und jetzt
finde ich es verhältnismäßig also das
ist für mich kein grund sondern die
begründung hätte eine andere er sein
müssen man kann jetzt so eine
impfpflicht stehen meinungen gehen
momentan sehr sehr sehr krass
auseinander leider ist es so man sieht
auch schon ein bisschen so eine gewisse
spaltung obwohl nicht durch die
ungeimpften in der minder meinung sind
aber sie werden dich immer sehr
radikaler in letztes hab ich jetzt
persönlich festgestellt aber ich sehe so
ihre these sehe ich es schon so dass ich
sage dir echtes die freiheit des einen
endet schon wo die freiheit des anderen
anfängt also man muss aktionen
verantwortung ist stunde verantwortung
auch hinsichtlich er der gemeinschaft
der mir heute die verantwortung eine
gemeinschaft nicht mehr wahrnehmen
würden würden wir dann im grunde
genommen ein
filmprojektor ist 19 jahre alt er ist
100 jahre alt und stand ich sage ich
sage ihnen etwas ich muss auch schon
jetzt kommt ich selber zu der
verhältnismäßigkeit ich muss dann schon
sein wollen wir in dem status wo wir
jetzt sind wir sind ganz genau wir
können das alles nur durchbrechen bengel
auf seine quote von ca 90 prozent kommen
das müssen wir einfach schaffen und
momentan wie es ausschaut schaffen wir
das so nicht anders bin ich dann dafür
dass sie viel schulschließungen bitte
bin was ist dann die am broadway wir
bevor wir jetzt die impfpflicht
debattieren das können wir auch sehr
gerne tun du hast ja auch die these vor
allem auch mitgebracht erst jesus nein
zu im pflicht jetzt ist es ja zur
pflicht die letzte liberale ich habe
heute einsatz in meinem sehr
persönlichen umfeld gehört und erst als
der satz gefallen ist habe ich so
gedacht nee das kann man nicht sagen das
ist ja total polemisch und jetzt werde
ich ihnen heute mit der runde teil zu
mir hat heute jemand gesagt na ja
übrigens selbst geimpft derjenige naja
nena zum wählen waren die ungeimpften
den politikern ja gut genug noch vor
etwas über acht wochen sie sollten ihr
kreuz setzen für olaf scholz auf
christian linder und jetzt plötzlich
nicht mehr und ich finde schon da es
hier nicht einfach irgendein
wahlversprechen geht ich bin auch der
meinung die politik hätte denn damals
sagen müssen ich bin nicht für die
pflicht ist kann aber sein dass sie
kommt sie haben aber klares nein zu
impfpflicht gesagt ich bin ja auch der
meinung ich teil da wirklich sehr die
meinung von sebastian arena das dem
stimme ich nicht zu und zwar das geld
das ihnen doch nicht nur den politik
kann so das ging der gesamten
gesellschaft so wir alle hätten uns vor
sechs monaten gegen eine impfung
oder vor 23 monaten der diskurs das ist
ja total spannend zu beobachten hat sich
um 180 grad gedreht wo gab es das in
dieser geschwindigkeit schon mal aber so
nicht geht er in der verzweiflung dass
wir jetzt die da eigentlich dort stehen
wo wir schon mal war bei seit einigen
tagen haben wir gerade keiner steigenden
zahlen also wo hat es sich so gedreht
dass wir so verzweifelt sind dass man
sie tatsächlich ein spannender punkt es
könnte gut sein dass wir die impfpflicht
dann bekommen werden wenn wir eigentlich
wieder unten bei der welle sind das ist
durchaus möglich aber bei der
impfpflicht geht es doch nicht um die
aktuelle welle sondern um die kommenden
wählen die dann noch sicherlich auf uns
zukommen also ich kann das schon in
gewisser weise nachvollziehen was mich
viel mehr stört also er ist ein absolut
absolut und was mich allerdings an der
debatte er stört ist wieder diese
schwarz-weiße diesen alternativlose
warum diskutieren wir nicht zum beispiel
eine impfpflicht für risikopatienten für
über 60-jährige für vor erkrankte das
wäre doch im sinne der entlastung oder
des schutzes unseres gesundheitssystems
das viel sinnvoller aber darüber reden
wir gar nicht wir reden immer nur für
alle oder keiner ich verstehe und im
grunde genommen genau das ist ja genau
was durch diese durch diesen unfall
entschuldige bitte die wortwahl
passiert ist dass unser parlament
aktuell in der mitte nur mit den konsens
tun lässt im feld allgemeine impfpflicht
für alle und das ist schwarz und weiß
das gibt es nur in extremen
beziehungsweise eigentlich nur in einem
extremfall so weit ich weiß halt die
linkspartei sich bedeckt aber im grunde
ist es doch nicht jetzt der einzige der
seine meinung jetzt geändert hat ist
muss eine logische
absage nicht warum man jetzt auf ein
lindner
vielleicht ist dann ja ok um debatte der
sogenannten freiheitspartei sie haben es
vielleicht ein also von dieser
begründung mich halt nur die begründung
gestört sonst bin ich ihm gar nicht böse
weil es ist natürlich ist niemand hat
inzwischen auch mehr erfahrungswerte man
sieht inzwischen auch dass drei viertel
von ihnen gewusst in hospitälern sind
dass ungeimpfte sind dass sie am meisten
übertragen ist davon hat man da hat mit
über auch nicht über diskutiert der sich
jetzt auch neue erfahrungswerte die man
hat die hatte man damals ja auch noch
nicht gehabt eine sache muss ich noch
ergänzen man wusste die ganze zeit das
weiß man seit der ganzen pandemie dass
man die lage nicht hundertprozentig
einschätzen kann also es war nicht so
dass jemand im sommer dachte wir
schätzen die lage so toll eine letzte
motto wir können jetzt sagen kann eben
nach gelungen ist
später nicht finde und das möchte ich
noch mal in aller deutlichkeit sagen
weil es mit um gewichtiges die
impfpflicht hätte niemals versprochen
werden dürfen das war ein wortbruch und
ich finde den furchtbar und damit möchte
ich nicht angreifen ist auch herr scholz
generell der wortbruch der politik ja
nicht nur der wortbruch der politik
sondern ich finde es fragwürdig wenn
dann niemand mehr vor allem den keine
liberale partei für die
entscheidungsfreiheit des individuums
sich noch stark macht und ich hätte sie
auch verstanden wenn er gesagt hätte wir
sind gerade in einer neuen regierung in
dieser konstellation bringen sind dafür
wir sind dagegen aber wir werden die
regierungslinie tragen hätte ich noch
verstanden aber die debatte wird immer
rohr und liebe mein thema schließt er
das ein bisschen anders an